on Friday night Saturday night get a
call to Oxford Circus
train station Tube Station to British
transport police officers have just been
severely beaten up by four jobs
again they've gone down there to tell
these Lads to go on because they were
terrorizing customers waiting for trains
in there and they had to switch them
beat them up pretty bad pretty bad right
cowardly thinks it though they weren't
that pissed they didn't know what they
were doing what I mean they were just
thugs
aside of course
um I I uh my colleague was driving a van
a sherpa van back and then just a bench
seats in the back you didn't have a cage
like it hasn't had cameras and all that
sort of palava
so we've put one of these scumbags in
the back of the uh police van
started a conversation with this with
this individual and I basically said
we're gonna have a straightener and I
took the Cuffs off him can you explain
what a strange Striker is we're gonna
have a fight